final report on a crash that killed five
cyclists good afternoon and thank you so
much for joining us here at four I'm
Christian Casas and I'm Vanessa Murphy
and this afternoon for Kirsten Saturday
will Mark the second anniversary of the
crash it happened south of the valley on
the 95 near Searchlight as the 8 news
now investigators uncovered last year
state troopers did not initially suspect
the driver who was high on meth was
impaired eight news now investigator
David Charles joining us live in studio
with what's in that report David well
Christian the federal report says the
driver's impairment from meth and
fatigue led to this crash that killed
the five cyclists and injured several
others as we reported Jordan Barson was
driving a box truck high on meth when he
crashed into that group but Nevada
Highway Patrol Troopers did not think
Barson was impaired though we'd find out
he would have as much meth in his system
as is often seen in corpses this report
citing the Biker's actions as a
contributing factor and that's something
true also said that day in the video you
were about to see that we obtained
they were in the number two
yeah they were writing in the number two
no
but the Nevada Department of
Transportation says cyclists are allowed
to ride on the highway in this rural
section on the 95 there is no rule
barring them from riding in the right
lane on the highway in our reporting
last year we asked a former DUI
prosecutor about the investigation
they were allowed to be there in the
road but even if they weren't
I don't see how when five cyclists get
killed too seriously injured
that an investigator at the scene says
oh they were in the they were in the
road at 10 A.M on a brightly lit day and
somehow this is not not a criminal act
anymore Barson ended up pleading guilty
to two counts of DUI resulting in death
remember five people died in that crash
right now he is serving a minimum
16-year prison sentence the NTSB saying
the cyclist quote contributed to the
crash because of their decision to ride
on that rural section on the 95 but as
we pointed out the law allows them to